-Kit, last time you were here.
First of all,
welcome back to the show.
Last time you were here,
we did a bit called
"Kit Harington Straight Up
Goes For It."
-Yes.
-And you just sang
"Drops of Jupiter" by Train.
That was the whole bit.
We asked probably
30 different celebrities
to do this throughout our years
being on the show.
And everyone said, "No."
You're the only one
with the guts to do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-And I will never forget that.
And I just want to know
from this appearance,
did you get any offers?
Just tell us what's up.
-Worryingly few, actually.
-You didn't get anything?
-Not a single offer
of anything musical,
which was surprising to me,
actually.
I got a few texts
from friends and family.
-That's nice.
-Yeah.
-They didn't know
quite why I did it.
[ Laughter ]
-Did they not --
But the best is
I go to you, I go,
"Kit, do you want
to do this bit?"
And you go, "Yeah, I don't
really sing."
I go, "That's the whole point.
That's exactly what we want."
-And then I got in here,
and you were like, "No one --
We've been asking people
to do this for years.
No one's done it,"
and I was like, "What?"
-Oh, yeah. I didn't want
to tell you --
I didn't want
to tell you that then.
I waited till you did the bit,
then I told you the truth.
Yeah, exactly, yeah.
How's your son doing?
-He's good. He's 2.
He's -- yeah, we think he's --
we think he might be
quite smart.
-Ooh.
-Which is...
-Oh, that's good.
-Yeah.
-That's a good thing.
-Well, it's surprising,
seeing as we're both actors.
No, we're like,
we're not sure where
that's -- quite where
that's come from.
-You don't want him
to be an actor?
-Well, we -- like,
he loves applause.
We like --
We sort of, every time
he does something good,
we give him applause,
and we're worrying
that's kind of pushing him
towards acting.
We're a bit like,
"Eh, you might be too smart
for this, you know,
go save the world.
We're sick, we had no choice.
-Yeah.
-But he's really good.
He's about to get the shock
of his life, which is that
he's about to get
a brother or sister.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you serious?
Congratulations. No way!
-Oh, yeah.
-Pregnant?
-Yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
-That's fantastic.
You got a new baby coming.
That's unbelievable!
-I know, I know.
Yeah --
-Are you excited?
Are you nervous?
-I'm so -- I'm terrified.
Like, I --
[ Laughter ]
You know, with the first baby,
you're, like, walking on clouds
and dancing through fields
of daisies for nine months.
-Yeah.
-Well, the man is, anyway.
[ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
-But this time you go,
like the reality check
comes much shorter.
You're, like,
you get practical real quick.
-Yeah, because you know what's
in store.
-Yeah, two of them.
-And what does you son think
about the new baby?
-I'm not sure
he's quite conceptually
understood it just yet.
He, like -- we're trying
to get him ready for it.
We point at Rose's tummy,
and we say, "Mommy's baby.
Mommy's baby."
-That's right.
-And he points at his tummy
and goes, "My baby."
-[ Laughs ]
-I'm quite sure that's --
that's, yeah, well,
you'll know soon enough.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
I saw that you recently attended
the "Game of Thrones" convention
in Los Angeles.
-Yeah.
-That's a --
[ Cheers and applause ]
What is that like for you
to go to those things?
It was like, it was a bit
like going back in time.
You know, I know it's only been
four years or something,
but it feels longer.
And I went to it,
and it's nice seeing the fans,
and it's kind of amazing
that that show
has still got such a fan base,
and it's continuing on
in its own way.
-Well, I mean,
there's rumors out there
that there's a there's
a "Game of Thrones" spin-off
that features your character,
Jon Snow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Is it happening?
-Well, I don't know.
Do you want to have it?
[ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
Yeah, I do want to have it.
I do want it.
I think people would love it.
-Yeah.
-I'd love to see you
as Jon Snow.
-Yeah, I can't say
anything on that,
but I don't know, man, like.
-Well, what -- what would stop
you from doing it?
Do you miss it at all?
-I walked down the street, and,
you know, I get recognized
a little less nowadays, and...
-Oh, wow.
-...and it kind of hurts my ego,
you know.
[ Laughter ]
No, I'm pretty close to,
like, putting on some furs, but.
-So it would --
So what would it take for you
to do this spin-off series?
Would it take -- Do you want us
to ignore you?
-Yeah, I think, like,
I've got a tally
in my head of how few photos
I get asked for in a day.
-Mm-hmm.
-And when it gets below
a certain number,
I think I'll do the spin-off.
Yeah.
-All right.
So fans of Kit Harington,
do not ask him for a photo
for the next --
If you do for the next two days,
by Monday,
we could have an answer,
and we could see
a "Game of Thrones" spin off
right now with Jon Snow,
all right?
We'll do this together.
We'll do it together.
Let's talk about your new movie,
"Baby Ruby".
Congrats. You play
a new dad in this film
when you were actually
a brand-new dad.
Did that help you
with the performance?
-Yeah, that was another level
of insanity.
Like, I left,
I mean, think about this --
I left a screaming child
at home to go and do a movie
about a screaming child.
-What's wrong with you?
-There's, like --
and on this set, you had twins.
So if one stopped screaming,
they'd bring the other one on.
You can't pinch your child
anymore, isn't it?
-Yeah, yeah,
you don't do that anymore.
-It's not allowed.
-No.
-Yeah.
-So that's wild.
But so you do this film,
which, by the way, it is --
it's a thriller, it's scary.
-Yeah, it's a kind of thriller.
It's a horror thriller
comedy thing.
-Yeah, kind of.
-You're allowed to laugh.
-You're allowed to laugh
at it a little bit, yeah.
-It's funny.
So it follows --
it's about postpartum psychosis
and about the lack of care
that mothers get after birth.
And so that's
an important message.
But it's really --
it's really not about me.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I had to put my ego aside.
It's not about you
for this one, yeah.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Kit Harington
in "Baby Ruby".
Take a look at this.
-Who wants Ruby?
-[ Breathing heavily ]
You're still wearing your apron?
-Yeah, well, your message,
it said you're in danger,
so I came as fast as I could.
And she's okay,
so no more sneaking around
where you don't belong.
Stay here. I'm gonna
go upstairs and get cleaned up.
You're gonna stay right here.
And then when I come back down,
we can talk, okay?
You're gonna by okay?
-Yes, sure.
-Good.
-Whoa! Come on!
Kit Harington, everyone.
"Baby Ruby" is in theaters
and on demand now.